this tutorial is a quick and simple
guide to no js' the Express framework
and MongoDB focusing on the fundamental
rest routes and basic database
interaction you'll build a simple API
boilerplate that can then be used as the
foundation for any app so this you
should have a basic understanding of
REST API s and crud operations which is
just create read update and delete and
you should also have some understanding
of some basic JavaScript knowledge I use
es6 mainly fat arrow functions but
nothing too complex for this tutorial
we'll create the skeleton of a back-end
for a note-taking app think something
like Google keep you'll want to be able
to do all four crud actions on your
notes like I was saying create read
update and delete special thanks to
Scott domes who wrote an article that
this video is based off of if you want
to see the original article you can
check the description ok let's get
started ok I created a directory for
this project just called notable I'm in
that directory in the terminal now if
you don't have node installed check the
link in the description for instructions
on how to install node so once you're in
the new directory we're just gonna run
NPM and net and then we're gonna follow
along with the prompts so for that we'll
just give it the name notable that's
already set there version 1.1 you know
we don't have to do with really any of
this stuff so I'm just gonna use the
default for all this yes okay once
that's done you should have a package
JSON ready to go in your directory so
this means you can just start installing
the dependencies you need for your
project you're gonna use Express as your
framework MongoDB is the database and a
package called body parser to help deal
with JSON requests so just do MPM
install save Express MongoDB body parser
and I also highly recommend installing
node Mon as a dev dependency it's a
simple little package that automatically
restart your server when files change
okay I got everything installed and now
I just open up the folder and sublime
text so I'm gonna go into the
package.json file right here and then
under scripts I'm just gonna add node
Mon server je s and we actually don't
we're not gonna use this test one so
I'll take that out and that should be
good on package JSON so I'm gonna save
that and now I'm gonna create my server
JS file and start building the API so
I'll go to new file server J yes so
first we're going to start by requiring
all our dependencies in server j s so
constic spresso constant [ __ ] client
Const body parser
and let's just align up everything here
okay and then finally const app express
you're going to use the [ __ ] client to
interact with your database note that
you also initialize your app as an
instance of express your framework the
last thing you need to do to get your
server up and running is to tell your
app to start listening for the HTTP
requests you can specify the port and
start to listening like so console.log
let's do a log here and we are live on
port now I'm going to save this I'll go
back to my console let me clear that if
I run npm run dev we should see an error
okay Express is not defined let's see
what we have to do here I spelled this
wrong so let's say that and go back over
okay it automatically saw the changes it
restarted and it says we are live on
8,000 so our server is live but it
doesn't do a whole lot or anything
really so let's fix that we're gonna
make some crud routes so for this
example we're gonna build four routes a
route to create a note to read your
notes to update a note and to delete a
note so this will give a good idea of
how to structure almost any basic route
with node to test the API we're gonna
need to mimic a client side making
requests so to do so we're gonna use a
great app called postman it allows you
to make simple HTTP requests with custom
bodies and parameters so to install
postman you can go to get postman comm
and you can download it for various
browsers there's also a Chrome extension
so I'm just gonna go to postman Chrome
extension
and add to chrome' so this is one of the
easiest ways to get it you don't have to
install any special program on your
computer and you don't even have to sign
up I'll just do take me straight to the
app okay once you get postman installed
it should look like this we're gonna
come back to this later so let's start
setting up our routes most nodejs
tutorials and many real apps put all
their routes in one big routes J's file
but we're gonna do something different
now we're going to split up the files
into separate folders and that's gonna
lead to good readability and makes big
apps more manageable now we don't have a
big app but let's do this right so we're
gonna make some directories in some
folders I'm just going to do it right
from the console you can do it from your
file browser or from sublime okay first
we'll stop the server so I'm just going
to make a directory called app and I'm
going to go into that directory and then
I'm gonna make a directory called routes
and then I'm just gonna go into that
directory and then I'm gonna make a file
called index J s and then I'm gonna make
a file called note routes j s okay we're
gonna go back into sublime text and
we'll see if there is showing up here
and you can see there right on the side
so are the index that Jas is empty and
then routes that J s is empty so these
directories may seem like overkill for
this simple small app but it's just
always good to start with best practices
and let's start with the C and crud
which is create so how would you create
a note well before you do that you have
to build a bit more infrastructure in
Express route are wrapped in a function
which takes the Express instance in a
database as arguments here's what I mean
in your note routes that J s we're going
to put module that exports equals
function
app DB just like that and then you can
export this function through your index
J s so let's start filling in that file
first we're gonna have a constant note
route equals require and we're gonna
require require the notes routes file
what we just exported and then module
dot exports and it looks like I made a
spelling error here so exports there we
go
no routes app DB so we're just going to
export that that route so basically the
index J s is our master route file and
then we have individual files for all of
our individual routes and we just bring
them all together in the index J s so
now that we've explored the routes here
we can import it in our server so back
in server J s we go right here and I'm
gonna put require require Apps slash
routes that's going to our directory so
this is how we're going to basically
import the route into our server know
that since you don't have a database yet
set up you're just passing in an empty
object that's why we just have an empty
object right here ok now we can make the
create route so the syntax is simple
we're gonna go back into our note routes
j s and we're gonna actually start
creating the route here so we're gonna
do apt outpost
here is where we'll actually create our
no so we'll create the note here but
right now we're just going to do res dot
send hello so when the app receives a
post request to the the notes path here
it will execute the code inside the
callback so that's the the callback
right here
so that's the callback right here and in
that callback it's gonna pass in the
request object which contains the
parameters or JSON of the request and a
response object which is used to reply
so we're gonna actually test this by
going into postman first let's make sure
all I'm gonna make sure all my files are
saved I'm gonna run my server again with
NPM run dev oh I have an error says
requires not defined I actually have a
spelling error you may have seen that
earlier so I just have to put require
here okay now that I've fixed that error
let's try running our server again and
another air let's looks like oh I see
what happened we spell I spelled the
word function wrong I'm a lot of
spelling errors here okay so now let's
try what hey let's see what happens or
it's restarting the server here and now
we're gonna finally get to test this on
node Mon so back in node Mon I'm going
to do a post request instead of get I'm
going to go to post here and now I'm
gonna put localhost 8080 can see it says
hello here it's pretty small it's pretty
small but if we go back into a file it
says res send hello so it just sent
hello when we did a post request to the
notes route so we just created our first
real route the next step is to add some
parameters to the request and
process them in the API and finally add
in the database so I'm going back into
post Mon I'm gonna try to zoom in a
little actually so it can so
everything's a little bigger and in the
body tab we're gonna add some key value
pairs after selecting the xww da form
- URL encoded so this will add encoded
form data to the request which will be
able to process with the API so we're
just gonna make a title my note title so
this is just some sample data body what
a great note now I before I send the
sample data I'm gonna go back into our
note routes and we're gonna do a console
dot log and I'm going to put rec that
body so we're just going to log out the
body of the request so I'll save that
and when I go back over here I'll send
this and then you're gonna and then
we'll see undefined you can see
undefined here that's because
unexpressed can't process URL encoded
forms on its own but we did install the
body parser package so let's go back
into our code we're going to go back
into the server and right below the port
I'm going to do app dot use body parser
that URL encoded and extend extended
true now it's going to be able to
process that correctly so if I save this
and I'm going to go back into postman
I'm going to send it send that again
let's go back into our server and now we
can see it title my node title body what
a great note the last step in the
preliminary route is to set up the
database and then add the data end
the easiest way to set up a [ __ ]
database is through em lab it's free for
the small size and quite fast to set up
so let's do that we're gonna go over to
our browser and we're gonna go to M lab
com
now you're going to create an account if
you don't already have one or for me I'm
just gonna log in okay after you get
logged in to in lab or you create an
account we're going to create a new
MongoDB deployment so I'm just going to
click create new and just click the free
one here
continue continue and I'm gonna call it
notable continue and submit order and
now I have to just create a user so
first I'm gonna go into the deployment
and go to user add database user so I'm
going to call it buh FCC and I put in a
password and create and now I just have
to copy this URL right here so I'm gonna
go to copy
okay now I'm in my console and I'm in
the root directory the notable directory
I'm going to create a configuration file
first I'm going to create a config
directory now I'm going to go into that
directory and now I'm going to create a
D bjs file where we're going to create
put our configuration for our database
so I'm gonna go back into sublime there
we go and here is my config directory I
just created and here's my database file
so in this file we're gonna add the URL
so module that exports equals this is
the URL we just copied on MongoDB URL
I'm gonna make sure it's in parenthesis
so I just copied this now I also have to
insert my username and password so the
username
is Bo FCC the password this is a very
secure password it's just password and I
will change the and a little bit here
now if you are gonna commit this project
to github you want to be sure to include
the dot git ignore file so that you can
so you don't share your password for
with everyone like I'm doing through
this video so now in the server JS file
we can use the [ __ ] client to connect
to the database and then use this to
wrap the app setup so let's see how to
do that
first we're going to require it so Const
DB we're requiring the database that
database configuration file require okay
now I'm going to line this up up here
and then down here we're gonna use the
[ __ ] client so a [ __ ] client that
connect so we can connect to the
database DB URL that's from the URL that
we just created in in the configuration
file and we're going to pass in we're
going to create a callback function
we're gonna pass in the air and the
database
and we're gonna check if there is an
error and if so we're going to return
we're just gonna log the air okay this
next part this text up here we're gonna
put into our [ __ ] to client connect so
I'm gonna cut this and I'm gonna put
right here so I just paste it in there
we're just going to change a few things
so instead of passing in an empty object
here I'm just going to pass in database
and actually that's all we're gonna
change so that's the last of the infant
structure setup it's all route building
from here
MongoDB stores data in collections which
are exactly how they sound in this case
we want to store notes in a collection
called notes so since we pass in the
database as the DB argument in the
routes see right here we're passing in
the database right here in the routes so
we can then access it like so well first
let's delete this this was just
temporary and if we write DB that
collection and notes so that's just how
we would access our database so creating
a note is it is as simple as calling
insert on the collections so we can put
dot insert and we pass in the note that
we we still have to create the note but
we're also going to pass in a callback
function with an air and results
okay so so we passed in the note here
I'm going to create the note right above
this line so Const note equals now it's
just going to be a JSON object and it's
gonna be a text is gonna equal rec that
body dot body so rec that body that body
just gets the the body variable from the
request so rec that body that body just
gets gets the body variable from the
request here so if we go into the -
postman we can see that we're passing in
the title and a body so that's where
we're getting that body there and so I'm
also going to create the note with a
title rec that body that title okay once
the insert is complete or has failed for
whatever reason we want to either send
back an error or send back the
newly-created no object so here's how we
finish this code up here if air res send
we're gonna send an air this is just
JSON here and error has occurred else
res that send result dot ops zero so the
result is going result that opt is going
to be an array here and we're just going
to send the zeroth element or the first
element in the array back which is the
note that we just created so let's try
out I'm gonna save this I'm gonna make
sure my server is running it is now
going to post man and we're gonna send a
X - W - form - URL encoded post request
with post man with a title and the body
just like we have here so I'm just gonna
click send and there was an error
connecting to the server so let's see
what we did wrong hmm
result is not defined okay here's the
problem I have results here and I've
resolved there so this was supposed to
be the same so result now it's a
singular and singular so let me say that
and we're gonna go back into postman
we're gonna send this again and here we
get we got this the text is what a great
note and the title is my note title so
we got this response from the server and
also assigned an ID to it so let's go
into in lab now so if we go into M lab
we go to collections and then I refresh
here we can see there's now a collection
called notes and in there what a great
note and my note title and it looks like
it create a note twice one for the error
and one foot for the one that did not
cause an error it still created a note
both times but the response caused the
error so it didn't show up in the
response and I actually can delete it
right through in labs I'm gonna hit the
delete button here okay so now we just
have one note in our database
now the read route we can pick up the
pace a bit so say you want to get back
the note that we just created by
navigating to let's say we wanted to go
to localhost 3000 slash notes slash and
then we put some ID so in this case the
idea would be this bit number right here
and I want to put that ID and then I
does that do anything no it doesn't but
we can easily create that so here's what
that would look like in the notes top
notes are out J s so we're gonna create
another route here I app get so instead
of a post it's a get so this is how we
get data from the server notes slash and
then ID we're gonna go to that route
note / ID wreck
res so it's pretty similar to this one
up here the app that post you have the
route and we create a callback function
with rec and res just like before we're
gonna call a method on the database
collection of notes so here it's gonna
be the aptly-named to find one we're
gonna find one element from the database
so first I'm going to create a variable
called details which is going to be the
element we're trying to get from the
database so it's gonna equal trying to
get something with the ID and the ID is
gonna equal well I'm just gonna put a
temporary thing ID goes here I have to
show you later how we're gonna actually
put the ID in there but first I'm going
to show you the rest of this code so if
we do DB dot that collection and note
that find one details we're going to
pass in the air and the item to this
callback function and now the air and
the result it's gonna look very similar
to this code down here so I'm just gonna
copy this and paste that in but instead
of the result that option 0 I'm just
gonna put item we're gonna return the
item which gets it gets it right from
here so let's go back to this idea up
here
now we could grab the ID from the URL
parameters via wreck that params that ID
however if you just try to plop in the
string into this above it won't work
MongoDB requires not just an ID as a
string but an ID as an object or as I
call it an object ID so that's actually
an easy fix to do we're going to have to
require something at the top so I'm
gonna do var var object
ID equals require MongoDB dot object ID
and then down here after the the git
command app that get when we put Const
ID equals rec dot params dot ID so now
this ID is just the string of the ID
from the quit that parameters in the URL
now we can film the rest of this so the
ID we're gonna take this off or says ID
goes here and I'm gonna put new object
ID ID so it's gonna create that ID as an
object to pass into to [ __ ] so let's
try it out I'm going to save this and I
check my server to see if there's no
errors and there is an error so let's go
back okay here's the problem I need a
parenthesis here and I have to take off
this parenthesis and want it I'll add
some semicolons okay let's go back to
the database to see if there's an error
okay no error so I'm actually this time
I'm gonna go to my browser and just
refresh this oh and this is actually
supposed to be eight thousandths of
3,000 so let's do that and it returns
with the ID the text what a great no and
my note title you can also do in postman
first of all let me copy this let's see
if that's the same one yep that's the
same ID so I'm gonna do a get and I'm
going to slash and then put the ID there
send that and yep it comes back with my
what a great note my note title and that
was directly from the database
okay now the delete route deleting an
object is actually pretty much the same
as finding an object
so I'm just going to copy the the get
code the find code because we're just
going to make a few changes to make it
the delete that delete code so we're
just going to use the instead of find
one we're going to use a remove all so
instead of get we have to show that it's
a delete request and then here instead
of sending back the item there is no
item so we're going to send note plus ID
deleted and let me put on their space in
here and that's the delete route and now
the update route this is the last one
the put is basically a hybrid between
read and create you find the object then
update it accordingly
so the put is basically a hybrid between
the read route that's this one and the
create route which is this one here
so you find the object and then update
it accordingly so I'm gonna copy this
one this one right up here almost put
right here so instead of get it's gonna
be put and this is gonna be the same
this is going to be the same but now I'm
gonna get this line from here that
Kant's note equals and then the the JSON
object for the text in the title I'm
gonna put it right here under the
details and now we're gonna change this
next line a little bit
DB collection notes dot update and we're
gonna pass in the details and the note
and then after we pass in the note
everything else is gonna stay the same
so let's go into postman and we're gonna
try these out so first of all let's try
this delete request so if I pass and
delete and send that over this note was
deleted and if we go back into MongoDB
and if i refresh
there is no longer a note in our
database so let's create another note by
doing a post and this time I'm gonna
have to pass in a body and I'll say my
note title and put some exclamation
points in here so it'll be different
we'll send that and if we get this ID
here I can now do a I get request send
that and we get that note back that we
just created and again it's gonna be in
MongoDB if i refresh MongoDB yeah our
note is there what a great note my note
title and if I go now we're gonna try
the put so here I'm going to pass in
this body so I'm going to go to this
route here but I'm gonna stead of saying
what a great note I'm gonna say what a
bad note and send that over okay let's
see if that worked we'll go over into
our MongoDB and refresh it and it's hard
to see here but it still says it says
what a bad note so it has changed and if
we go back we can even do another to get
to see what it is so if I sent a get
what a bad note so now we have every
route in crud we have create read update
and delete note the imperfections in
this code if you fail to supply a body
or title the put request will nullify
those fields on on the note in the
database you could easily add some
conditional logic to update the fields
only if they're present in the request I
left that out just to keep it simple
well that's it you have a working node
API with each of the four major crud
operations the goal of this tutorial was
to give you a degree of familiarity with
express node and MongoDB you can use
your simple app as a launching pad for
more complex projects
his bow Karnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good